is a hard reboot of the Stargate
franchise still a risk how worried
should we be welcome to Sidetrack your
Sci-Fi TV movie channel
[Music]
we have always said on this channel that
the longer it takes for Amazon to
actually get off its ass and order the
Stargate new series new movie whatever
they want to do the longer it takes them
the more likely that it would be to be a
hard reboot I was actually told
um about a year ago now that if we
hadn't heard about the Stargate
franchise by roughly spring this year
three or four months ago then it was
really very unlikely that we were going
to be getting a franchise anytime soon
and that in fact that made the hard
reboot even more likely now I actually
told you on a live a couple of nights
ago that I've been talking to one of my
sources who's giving me a massive update
on what's going on in the Stargate
franchise and what Amazon's plans are
and one of those plans does maybe
include a hard reboot
but I'm going to tell you about that in
a second so the sauce a year ago what
changed why haven't we had an
announcement why shouldn't we maybe be
too worried about what they believed at
least then well back then we didn't know
about the strikes we didn't know that
this was going to get to this point now
actually by around March Time Amazon
apparently were very concerned about the
strikes they actually started to put a
lot of contingency plans into place and
they basically agreed even as early as
then that they wouldn't be announcing
all the things that they wanted to
announce at San Diego Comic-Con or other
Comic Cons this summer they were hoping
to announce RoboCop Stargate etc etc but
they very quickly realized that just was
not going to happen now when the
Directors Guild signed their deal there
was a hope within a lot of the studios
that maybe the writers would follow suit
there was a hope that maybe they could
avoid the actors going on strike and at
least keep some of their projects going
but when the actors did go on strike
again the writers stayed on strike that
became very obvious very quickly that
that was simply not going to happen
so what my source told us a year ago was
true then however events have changed
things have changed and Amazon's plans
have changed now go back and look at my
SGU animated movie now even though that
video I'm not 100 certain how accurate
that information is I do think it's
interesting that Amazon might be
actually going a different Direction
with their plans they're not the sort of
company to just sit on their hands and
wait so I actually think the strikes
make an animated Stargate project
something they could be working on now
while they're waiting for everything
else to kick off that is actually
possible but what about the hard reboot
of the franchise is that now more likely
or less
well again as I told you in the live
just a couple of nights ago my source is
telling me that apparently a new
director has actually been found at
least informally for the movie that is
planned the Cinematic movie that Amazon
are hoping to kick this franchise off
with they have been talking to this
director for a little while now and they
have at least in principle agreed
nothing will be actually signed no
contract signed until after the strikes
now but at the moment they are actually
talking about some development I told
you the director did raise the point
that if he feels necessary is the door
to a hard reboot open or closed and
Amazon apparently answered we don't want
a hard reboot but if you do we'll talk
about it
opening up the possibility that whoever
this director is we we don't know yet
but whoever this director is if they
decide they want to do a hard reboot to
the Stargate franchise Amazon won't
necessarily stand in their way now that
is a big change in Amazon's standing now
I completely understand why they would
at least agree to have maybe the
conversation they found the director
they want we believe they've got the
development team they want and then once
they've chosen that director that
director comes to you and says you know
am I am I tied down to this you at the
very least seriously consider what
they're telling you this is the person
you've picked to lead the ship this is
your captain you have to listen but we
know from what Roland emmerich said well
over a year ago now in an interview when
asked about this that actually Amazon
were probably even then thinking about a
movie he said though that he wouldn't be
involved in any major way in whatever
Amazon did because it was very clear to
him that the only thing they cared about
was the TV audience now my sources have
been telling me basically for two years
now that Amazon never wanted to do a
hard reboot they do think SGU sg1 and
SGA are the most important part of this
franchise and that they never wanted to
do Roland emerick's plan to do a hard
reboot and actually do the trilogy of
Stargate movies he planned all those
years ago Amazon basically don't want
the bad press that a hard reboot would
give them they know how much we love
Stargate they know how much we love
these characters and they don't want to
have a rings of power problem on their
hands where basically they get loads of
negative press before the project is
even made they also must know that
Nostalgia is always reasonably popular
when it's done properly Picard season 3
recently proved that very point so I
have never believed that a hard reboot
was a major risk I do know that some of
the people that actually did Pitch
towards the end of last year including
people like a Bad Robot and
um the guys who do the boys and a couple
of other production companies when they
were pitching their ideas some of them
did Pitch hard reboots they did say look
there are lots of problems with us just
Reviving this show by the end of sg1
we've got loads of Starships
they see the Stargate for some reason is
still a secret
um we've got all this technology we've
become gods
how do we progress that series there's a
reason why Brad Wright switched to SGU
because he identified that problem even
back then
so there are issues it would be a lot
easier in some ways to do a hard reboot
now I imagine that's where this director
is coming from so I actually am not too
worried about the hard reboot problem if
we've got good people in charge of the
development work and we think we do
because we think it's Haw Coast B and
Mark Fergus the guys that did the
expanse if we do have good people in
charge and they come up with good ideas
the director I am sure will go with
those ideas it seems to be that the
director at very least in the back of
his mind knows that some of these things
are real problems and that actually in
some ways it might be better to do a
hard reboot now I don't think we should
be necessarily terrified of the hard
reboot word because at the end of the
day if they bring back a hard reboot and
it's brilliant
five years down the line we won't care
people went nuts when Ronald D Moore did
the hard reboot about a Star Galactica
and very quickly those critics shut up
so it is possible that actually Amazon
could take a massive risk and it could
pay off we won't know until it's on our
screens we won't probably know until
we've seen a couple of things you know a
couple of movies a couple of TV series
but it is possible that that is the way
to go it's not the way we want to go
though so I am hopeful that the
development team will actually think of
some brilliant ideas to convince the
director that this is the only way but
to answer the initial question How
likely is it how at risk are we of
getting a hard reboot
I'm just going to say look it's possible
it's always been possible but Amazon
don't want to do it they will have to be
convinced the people like Jennifer
salking are not convinced so
if the director is going to go that way
he's going to have to have a bloody good
argument why and if that argument is
compelling enough to convince the people
at Amazon then I think as Gators we have
to at least give it a chance
sg1 SG Atlantis and SG universe will
always be there we will always be able
to go back and spend time with those
characters
but maybe we'll get a load of new
characters to fall in love with all over
again
remembering that actually in lots of
ways sg1 was a reboot of the movie
an awful lot was different
and we fell in love with that quickly
enough
so let's see what the coming months hold
we have to wait for the strikes to end
and then hopefully we're going to get an
announcement really really quickly
unless Amazon decide to do something
completely crazy and just announce it
out of the blue
I'd be okay if they did but in the
meantime I will keep my ear to the
ground and I will keep telling you about
everything and anything that comes up in
the Stargate Universe hopefully we'll
find out that nugget of information that
can keep us going just these next couple
of months until we finally get the
official announcement
but guys I'd love to know what you think
about this news so please get into the
comments is the director insane or
actually are they just being sensible
thinking about the projects as a whole
thinking about the big picture and at
the end of the day if the plans for
development just aren't right maybe they
should be scrapped and maybe they should
just start from the beginning
maybe I'd love to know what you think
get into the comments if you are new to
the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification it really helps
us out and you'll never miss any of our
new videos also you can go to
patreon.com forward slash Sidetrack
where most of our new videos appear
first and for some more contribution
each month that really supports the
channel and you get a free gift after
three months you get to see them without
the adverts as always please stay safe
and I'll see you next time
thank you